I love you so much 127 hours this is a
review that I did not think I would be
giving I just wasn't sure if I could
take this movie I've heard so much stuff
about the the scene you know the thing
that he has to do and I was like watch
it this movie stars James Franco it's
directed by Danny Boyle of Slumdog
Millionaire it's about a free-spirited
climber hiker travel or whatever he
likes to go and do things on the spur of
the moment kind of and not really tell
anyone where he's going so he goes and
he's he's hiking in this Canyon he falls
down a crevasse and gets his arm jammed
between a huge rock and the wall Danny
Boyle did something really smart
throughout that whole beginning of the
movie like the first 15 minutes it's
very fun and you know he's meeting
people that that are also hiking and you
know bla bla bla bla
as soon as he gets stuck in there all of
a sudden the movies title just appears
127 hours you're like okay this is when
the movie actually starts so from that
point on the movie is about James Franco
trying to get out of that position this
is a true story about a man named Aron
Ralston hiker who was in this very
situation himself now I'm sure as many
of you know this is not a spoiler if you
don't know what ends up having to take
place stop watching this review after
five days of struggling running out of
water and having no food he's forced to
amputate his arm now I heard that some
people actually fainted while watching
this film
many people just had to close their eyes
and couldn't take it I didn't close my
eyes I didn't look away but I can't tell
you that for a large portion of this
movie I kind of look like this just a
little on edge when it came time for the
scene it wasn't him just like doing it
it was just a lot of quick flashes
really the thing that really made the
scene kind of difficult to watch was the
sound
FEX because they didn't actually show
that much it was just there was lots of
sound and actually kind of more of the
knowledge of knowing what was happening
I'm having a hard time kind of summing
up my feelings towards this film because
I know it was a very good film very very
well made James Franco is excellent in
this film a lot of heart into his
performance however if someone ever
asked me if I wanted to watch this film
again I guarantee I would say no now
it's a great movie however it's not an
experience I really want to go through
again I think Danny Boyle uses close-ups
a little too much and a little bit too
much glare you know from the Sun and
stuff but he does an excellent job with
this direction you really feel for this
character as the film ended I was like
dude just do it already man you gotta
get out of there I mean I was as rooting
for him to do it really the stars of
this film are Danny Boyle and James
Franco I mean there's nothing really
else to critique cinematography was
really great throughout the whole movie
I was just kind of like okay you know
just do it oh I'm gonna watch how he did
it oh he's doing it oh there it is okay
well it's not that bad oh well it's kind
of bad oh it's over the reason this is a
good film is because it's hard to
critique because the film is actually an
experience I wasn't watching it as if
mmm how are they filming this scene or
how does this look it was just like oh
what's he gonna do now I mean I was in
the world of this film I was there with
that character and I wanted him to get
out of there and so for that reason
alone this is an excellent film if
you're looking for a good time in the
movies this is not the kind of film
you're going to want to go see if you're
feeling maybe sad about your life then
maybe this is a film that'll make you
appreciate your life little more in fact
when this movie ended I actually wanted
to just go find like everyone I care
about and just be like thank you for
being here and being alive I just wanted
to find like everything I loved hug it
this is a very inspirational movie but
like I said this is no fun entertainment
film you know what I mean I mean this is
that this is a film that it's just it'll
stick with you and it shows a lot about
what a human can do if he's pushed to
the ends of his life the James Franco
excellent Danny Boyle great direction it
is one of the best films of 2010 I think
chances eat so now I'm gonna give under
27 hours four out of four stars
excellent film but not very good reap
site value simply because I never want
to watch it again